Good experience.
No,
the guy who has the accordion,
the monkey dance,
monkey dance isn't.
I love the sound of the accordion and I just,
uh,
I saw it and I just wanted to bring something to the new studio and like how you
have a lot of weird shit here.
And this is weird that somebody loved this sound so much that they decided let's
make an instrument out of it.
Yeah.
Are there like,
real complicated ones?
Those are like big.
Do people play them in orchestras and shit?
No,
I don't think they ever made it into the orchestra.
So it's never been like a really respected piece of musical instrument design.
Co,
New Orleans,
buckwheat,
Zydeco.
You ever hear that back?
Like polka lot of Polish Polka Zam fear,
master of the Pan Flu.
Of course.
What happened to that poor bastard?
Like he had a whole marketing team behind me.
They're like,
dude,
no one's done this.
No one's done this,
but we're going to do this.
You can master the Pan Flute,
Dvds,
cds,
vhs tapes.
We're going to sell it all.
There's literally no competition.
There's nothing you can do your exam fear.
He's the Tony Hawk of the Pan Flute,
right volume with this guy,
beautiful music
radio and the chest hair and change one gold chain records around the world.
20 million records.
What
zone?
Peter?
In his magnificent.
It looks like a guy that works in the Deli.
That is a very forgettable sound.
It's a recorder.
It's for like when the.
One of the things you learn when you're in fourth grade and they teach them
music.
Yeah.
That goofy flute like thing.
I never.
I never paid attention to the recorder because they gave me the recorder and I
go,
well,
how come I don't see this band's
the fuck out of here.
I'm not going to spend some time learning an instrument that no one plays.
You need to carry it in your sock.
You remember you had to put in your slack.
They didn't even have cases.
Leave this,
gave you a good old tube sock from your dad and put it in there right now.
Makes a case for the fucking recorder.
Now you have to put in your dad's sock and it didn't make any sense either that
it was.
Oh,
he's got it.
He was tall,
but he plays a flute,
right?
Well,
it said pamphlet when I typed it in,
but flute rock flew.
Well,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
JETHRO tull.
He's quitting.
Crazy looking dude.
He looks like he lives in a hollowed out tree,
right?
He does.
Oh my God.
Scurries out.
When you walk by on the trail.
I know his.
Anybody else figured out how to use the flute in rock and roll music besides
Jethro Tull?
We need to know we're not alone.
Yes.
When all our madness.
What was it like on the set when you were working with Dave Chappelle?
It was great.
Well,
I've known Dan for a long time.
I was actually on the very first episode we by chance I was walking through New
York and I saw dave and this was before the show had.
Even Beth.
I didn't even know it existed,
but I rented a Bobcat Goldthwait who's there and I'm like,
what's up man?
What do you guys do?
And he's like,
he goes,
oh,
hey joe,
we're doing a TV sketch,
man,
you want to be in on it?
And I go,
I only have like 20 minutes away to a meeting.
He goes,
here he goes,
we're handing out ribbons for New York boobs.
And he had a box,
so it's me and him walking through Manhattan and he's got this crazy fake
mustache on and he's like,
you've got the best New York boobs anyway,
to give someone like a ribbon for heaven,
New York boobs.
And it was really silly but fun.
And so I was like,
well,
Dave's got a show.
And then turns out it's the greatest show in the history of the world.
And a year later he calls me up again and asked me to do this thing for.
They wanted to do a fear factor sketch with tyrone Brigham's.
Yeah.
So that's me and him.
A fresh faced Joe Rogan and Dave Chappelle bit you.
Yeah.
Well this is like,
what year is this?
Yeah,
I think it's before that is it.
I think it's before that,
I want to say it's 2002 maybe.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
I wasn't even doing the show back then and I was doing that in 2003,
so I think it's 2002.
Uh,
the fear factor bit is one of my favorite.
That's a season two,
if I recall.
Think so.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
is really one of the areas,
one of the funniest bits in a show that is,
I would argue
perhaps the greatest television show of all time.
I think it's the greatest sketch comedy show of all time.
Something bigger.
It's hard to say that though,
because if you boil down a lot of the all time great shows,
like in living color or some of the other ones.
Boy,
they had so many seasons.
If you boiled them down to two seasons,
maybe there would be some.
But he's got some sketches that worst just groundbreaking,
like the black white supremacist who was blind.
Yeah.
What about,
I was watching last night because jeff and I were talking about last night on
the car ride home from this event we did together.
I was watching black Bush,
which was another,
I think unbelievably,
which released season two where he plays George w dot Bush,
his version of Georgia and all the rationales for going into the war in Iraq and
it's unbelievably funny.
Yeah,
he's a genius.
He's a real comedy genius,
but also a guy who's.
You don't,
you wouldn't get it if you just sort of see him do standup,
but he's deeply introspective,
like very intensely.
Well thought out,
you know,
he's not,
he's not a surface guy by any stretch of the imagination.
Sure.
But it ended up being just this amazing finish.
So anyways,
when I tell Ari I want to go to this,
I'm kind of thinking that's the Ballpark,
like because that's the only experience I have.
So the games in Atlanta,
he buys tickets and I'm like,
I go,
you're not flying me coach,
you know that.
He's like,
no,
you go first bird rookies coach.
He was
coach,
I'll them a seat belt extension.
Oh cool.
But Brian ended up going from somewhere else.
So anyways,
he bought the ticket.
He got an Airbnb,
a really nice house,
you know,
for a few days in Atlanta and then it's a,
it's the big thing that is game day.
I'm thinking like,
oh that's cool that you got these tickets and you got,
you know,
but I think it's reasonable and then we get to the stadium.
It was a total fucking disaster to get in because trump went to the game,
so it was raining,
it was wet secret service everywhere to our lines to get into the venue and I
paid a guy,
a security guy 100 bucks to walk us through the line,
which is,
which was almost impossible because it was so packed.
But I dunno,
he just started walking us through the line,
like in front of people.
People were yelling at the security guy,
which was like so uncomfortable.
He's like a young black kid and like old white people,
where the fuck are you doing?
He's like,
I'm security.
And they're like,
you're not just security you piece of shit like right to is right in front of
us.
And I was like,
God damn,
like I just have never seen someone flip out like that.
What we were doing was highly unethical.
We shouldn't have done it.
But like we just weren't going to wait in that line.
And then burt,
of course,
Bert in a crowd like that,
he's like,
it's okay.
I'm famous.
Were famous guys like yelling that to people,
which is like,
no,
you did.
Oh absolutely.
He's like,
he's like,
we're everywhere we went.
If we went to a restaurant they would come and be like,
Hey,
can I get you guys something to drink?
And he'd be like,
do recognize,
like they were like,
what was he serious?
I think it's part of his like,
you know,
whatever style.
And then.
And they were like,
I'm sorry,
so part of a joke or part of a joy,
he's joking but I'm not.
He's like halfway in the middle because one time,
one time he was like,
we're famous comedians.
And The lady was like,
Oh,
I know who you are.
And he was like,
isn't that awesome?
Being famous guys shut up.
And he was serious.
He's like,
half serious.
but it's like you see him in his element.
It's like him in with crowds is really like,
you realized that he really enjoys it.
Like he really enjoys the large groups.
He enjoys being recognized.
He fucking like sometimes we were walking and people were like,
Hey,
you're the guy.
I've seen you on facebook.
He was like,
you want a picture?
And they're like,
okay,
yeah,
he loves it.
He loves it.
And then we,
we're talking about how like people would say,
like,
Tom and I were like,
yeah.
And they're like,
hey.
And then they would walk away.
They wouldn't come over to me.
They were like,
hi.
And then they'd walk in another way,
but with birth they're like,
can I hug you?
Then take their shirt off.
They say,
yeah,
I love.
I think 55 is an amazing way class right now.
We argue on Fox that they think they,
they try to get under my skin and say lightweight is the best.
Divisional said don't play with me.
After Habib B was a beast,
I watched any of his fights.
I watch them.
I'll say I need to go back to my,
um,
my math.
He fights like that every time he's a monster.
See the Michael Johnson fight.
He's telling me to give up.
It must be champ.
Give up,
smashing them his wrestling and his,
his,
his ground and pound.
It's just so ferocious.
It's just on such another level.
And when he gets a hold of guys,
he's getting ahold of guys that are really good and just ragdoll and I'm like,
what?
He did the RDA GMC that fine.
I haven't seen those fines.
I got to go back and look ragdolled rds and then she just beats the shit out of
people.
It gets you to the ground.
I was a big fan at that and I'm like,
man,
he's something special.
Something special.
And the fact that he did that to Barboza he wants to move up to 72 shit.
No he don't.
Hey,
metabolic meals shit out and sit in and see my man.
Habib the pack.
Nutrition.
Is anybody out there?
I'm picking up the tab cycle as down to 55.
I'm not trying to see.
No.
Could be right now.
Yeah,
he's making 55 easy now though,
so who knows?
I think what I believe is going to happen is I think Connor's going to vacate.
I think they're going to strip them because connor has got $100,000,000 in the
bank.
I think he's having fun and talking shit and he's going to keep training and
he's going to make a big fight in the future,
but I think Khabib versus Tony is the big fight and fuck.
They might even do that one in Russia.
Would they do that one?
They're talking about doing a big fight in Russia that.
Yeah,
if that happens,
well that's a good fight.
I mean,
everybody's been waiting to see that fight.
Fuck yeah,
that's good.